this meeting is being recorded
okay good evening everyone and welcome
to the uh employment committee meeting
um
item number one is the uh attendances uh
to know the attendances and any
apologies are we aware of any apologies
this evening
early apologies for tonight alex
i've received
apologies from council boyd and council
london okay great i think i think
do we need to sort of acknowledge
those that can't get in
because i think joanne bennett can't get
in on i think she's he i think javon
she's here
i don't know if there's anyone else
struggling to get in
no it's okay i think one bennett's on my
screen anyway so
hopefully
hopefully she's here in some form
right yeah
okay so we're happy with that and move
on to uh item number two which is the
minutes
um is everybody happy with the the
minutes that we have there for the
meeting held on the 13th of december
yeah i'll move on
i'm geology do you want to come in there
yes i'll just come in because there are
two things i just need to bring your
attention to from the minutes of the
last meeting
and so at the last meeting i mentioned
that i would bring a report on our
equalities and employment position and i
updated you all that we've been working
with an external consultant from the
association of public sector excellence
and they've done a review of our hr
policies from an equalities lens
to ensure that we're doing all we can to
meet compliance in our commitments with
challenging inequality discrimination
and disadvantage
so with the need to divert our hr
resources to support the pandemic
response at the time the report from the
consultant has been subsequently delayed
and we met last week um but it was too
late to bring a report back into this
committee and because they're now just
finalizing the recommendations
so just for reference for these minutes
i will defer this item and bring the the
report into the next employment
committee in june and for information so
that was the first thing i just wanted
to bring your attention to and there's
one other thing
and again connected with the minutes and
that was um
the request for information from
councillor bennett on the number of
social worker vacancies
um and that was to be provided to the
committee meets committee members after
the last meeting
so just to update that that information
should be with you all but it was only
sent today so apologies for the lateness
in sending the information but you
shouldn't have the information in your
inboxes today
so
great thank you very much any other
comments on that anyone
john have you got your hand up or are
you just
right i don't think council holder won't
say anything at the moment i'm back
sorry now i'm doing technical things
with my studio
no problem i didn't want to make it okay
you know
if you have something requesting to say
yes okay so um we're happy with that
then moving forward for the uh for the
subsequent meetings
um
item number three is questions from the
public not aware of any of those are you
alex
questions have been received from the
book
okay great
uh so we'll move on to item number four
then uh which is the people update
that's that's with me a counsellor right
so
i'll just take you through the um the
people update so
um as we head into 2022 our recovery
from the pandemic continues
um and the hr service also continued to
support council in a number of workforce
related
and this is so managers can lead their
teams well and start to build their own
recovery plans from covid as we
thankfully start to return to a more
business as usual state
so i'm going to pull out some of the key
highlights from from the update that we
have on the agenda today from each team
um so in terms of our health and safety
team they continue to keep our workforce
feeling safe
and working closely with our public
health team and kate's policy team
ensuring that our advice for colleagues
who
catch covid is to continue to work at
home where they can
and until the advice changes again on
the first of april when testing
potentially ceases we are maintaining
our approach to advising colleagues to
test and to stay at home
and our reintegration planning is going
well
and for returning back to the office on
a more permanent footing
and arrangements have been put in place
to ensure that staff continue to feel
safe there and that's so important and
we're going to see higher numbers of
staff returning to work in the office in
time for spring and hopefully some nicer
weather
um
mentioned previously
that we have procured some yellow
lanyards available for those staff who
still want to maintain some distance
um and
they're they're available people have
already got them and will make sure that
they're available for those that still
want to as i say continue to maintain
social difference
and we're reiterating the importance of
our
hygiene measures and for those that want
to wear face coverings these these will
be optional in the future
we're also piloting a desk and meeting
green booking system so that as we move
more into um
sort of business as usual um return back
to the office we're going to be moving
into a more hybrid way of working
um so that staff won't be in the office
all of the time and they can touch down
in their designated areas floor plans
have been shared
with um staff and the communications
team will be cascading key messages
between now and the end of march so that
everybody's really clear on where they
potentially will sit and how we want to
use the office space um
in the future
so
our
well-being theme um is hashtag
stay epic this winter
and we've had a campaign in place um to
support our colleagues to look after
their own health and well-being and
check in on others
over the winter period then we've had
lots of different themes covered over
the months of december through to
february covering things um like
physical mental and financial well-being
with new resources being added
through our internet pages each month on
a rolling basis
some staff stories have also been shared
and this is to encourage storytelling
and sharing and coping strategies
we've launched a really powerful video
of one of our colleagues talking about
his own mental health experience
and that's
encouraged further stories from
colleagues about being an epic pioneer
in a mental health first data for
example and one from a colleague about
their hidden disabilities and support
they get from attending the staff
disability group
so really really positive stories um
there
our epic manager program offer is going
from strength to strength we're now in
our 18th cohort and this program
supports our values our ambitions to
continue to
empower our managers to adopt the more
of a coaching leadership style and
supporting our colleagues to develop and
grow that also promotes
what we're calling our grow our own
talent strategy which is one of the key
strands of our people strategy
so we've currently got 10 colleagues
undertaking a level 5 coaching
apprenticeship
across all age ranges
and 31 colleagues undertaking a coaching
relationship with a qualifying coach and
we're also promoting coaching for
managers
service throughout various
communications and so far 31 people
are using the service which kind of
speaks for itself really
so our policy reward and intelligence
team continue to keep us safe from
employment challenge there are two
reports on this agenda that kate who
leads that team is going to present
one of which is the annual pay policy
statement
and the other is pensions discretions
policy refresh
so they've been working on those two um
policy positions amongst lots of other
things as you can see in the update
one of the things i will draw your
attention to
is the working world passport
and this is something that's been
developed as a direct result of feedback
from a colleague who attends the
disability staff group
so this is a document which can be used
by staff to detail information about
their individual needs and any support
or adjustments that they have agreed
with their manager so that if their
employee manager changes they can share
the passport with them it's a great
example of where you know we've listened
to feedback we've taken that feedback
forward and the team of co-produced and
employment initiative that hopefully
will will benefit um a wide range of
people for that you know they they
ideally tell the story once
um
it's something that we've taken on from
um colleagues in in the nhs where that's
you know kind of working quite
successfully
um so our hr ops team continues to
support managers with employment law
advice and guidance and this is to avoid
costly and resource intensive employee
relations cases and matters escalating
the one hr front door is
working with closely with our greater
manchester shared service colleagues and
that continues to evolve
we've recently moved our schools team
into that
model so that schools obtain hr advice
from from this service
so the team continued to provide a wide
range of often complex employment advice
and working closely with kate's team
they continue to develop and deliver
training to managers so that they can be
even better
people managers
and then our resourcing team continues
to be really busy whether that's
supporting managers with business as
usual job advertisements and recruitment
key vacancies in a timely way or working
with them on more targeted strategies to
support in areas where there are
particularly
you know um recruitment difficulties and
or where service delivery might be
compromised and that's usually in our
frontline services supporting our most
vulnerable residents
they're also supporting our employment
initiatives aimed at increasing job
opportunities
we have our young people through the
kickstart scheme
and i updated at the last meeting i'm
delighted to say that cohort one all
have graduated
and six out of the nine young people
have gained ongoing employment within
the council the other three have also
attained job opportunities elsewhere or
are taking up university placements
so a really really successful outcome
um recruitment to our next cohort has
started and so far we have 10 young
people recruited into that cohort and he
will be taking on placements across the
council and to finish off um we've also
got six internships in our library
services that are really successful from
united response
working across the service on a road to
basis across the year
working in partnership with ua 92
so
hopefully you can see over the last six
three months or so you know the hr
service has been supporting colleagues
and and managers to continue to lead and
manage services well during what again
has been a really
unprecedented um
uh time um in in the calendar so um i'll
stop there and make any comments or
questions
thank you very much that was uh very
thorough it's fantastic report so thank
you very much for it and especially keen
to hear about all the you know the
positive stuff for the kickstart which
sounds amazing so
thank you very much for that does anyone
have any comments
questions
anyone yeah
yeah i've got my hand open yeah it was
just about the kickstart scheme actually
because i i noticed in the
jcc minutes that there was a note about
it
and it appears that the numbers are
dropping off i just i just i just
wondered what the reason
for that was
and also i noticed recently was a bit of
negative press nationally about the
scheme
i think another way it was the national
audit office saying that
they didn't think it was value for money
or they didn't think it was effective
and
i gather from what you said angela it
doesn't seem to be our experience so
i just wondered
you know if you've got let me comment
about it really
i think i think firstly in terms of the
numbers um cohort two we did struggle um
to get attention and i think that was
mainly because of the success of the
initial um scheme and the numbers of
young people you know had lots of
opportunities to
um take up placements right across
greater manchester so i think cohort two
we did struggle to get the numbers but
as i say in cohort three we've got ten
young people who are
just about to start their placements
with a wide variety of services right
across the council and i think i think
it's down to the employer
to maximize you know the the
opportunities that you know kind of
bringing in young people
presents
um so you know and what we've done in
traffic is we've done a lot of work
wrapping around a support package to
these young people
to enable them so when when they start
their placements they've had an
intensive two-week
wrap-around support which kind of gets
them ready you know for the world of
work so
i think it's it's back to how they how
they're in the employer wants to
uh nurture young talent and i think in
trafford you know as i said earlier in
the update you know growing our own
because these are traffic children
traffic young people it's really
important to us
that we we give traffic young people
opportunities that perhaps they might
not ordinarily get in the world of work
so it's how we nurture and develop and
grow and spend that time working with
them and you know the success of which
does actually pay off
in the longer term
thanks angela um yeah apologies if i've
got it wrong because i read there was
only two in cohort three i think it
less than a minute or incorrect but if i
misunderstood that i do apologize but
thanks for the update anyway it's very
positive
uh dave did you want to come in next
yeah it was just about uh obviously
um phasing people back into the town
hall
um
and i i was wondering
whether we would be utilizing
uh the council chamber um
and
you know particularly for council
meetings uh because i'm sure it's quite
expensive to
uh you know
actually go around the borough
booking
these rooms so we have to book
so so
i'm wondering
when that is likely to happen
so i think that's going to be imminent
um counselor acton i mean we'll take a
conversation offline because the paper
is going um you know for consideration
around
how we start to get back to more
business as usual state i think as the
government does relax the restrictions
further and further
and as i said earlier when the testing
ceases on the first of april
we will be in a much more different
environment so i think you know the use
how we use the building and that
includes the council
chambers and the me and the subsequent
meeting rooms will also follow suit so
yeah absolutely it will
happen um as in this next phase of
reintegration
yeah thank you
anybody else any comments questions on
that one
i don't see any hands or anything so if
we're happy to move on
um
we move on to uh item five which is the
pay policy statement to consider report
from the interim director of human
resources
so i'm just going to introduce the the
paper and then i'm going to bring um
kate in to and take us through the paper
so
um the pay policy statement sets out the
council's approach to pay policy um in
accordance with the requirements of
section 38 of the localism act
2011. it's an annual report it comes
here every year at employment committee
prior to recommending it on to full
council for approval with any amendments
that you you might want to make um and
full council is on the 23rd of march
so without further ado i'm going to
bring kate in now and ask her to just
take it through the
australian
good afternoon everybody so yeah that's
obviously detailed i'm just going to put
a couple of highlights which are
actually positive trends
um so first of all we're just focusing
on the pay ratios
so we monitor our pay ratios to
understand how the salary of our most
senior officers compares with our lowest
paid staff and also average employees as
well
um and we wouldn't want to see the
ratios increasing so a downward trend is
positive or stability on the ratios
so this year we can see that the ratio
of our chief executive and that of our
median earner is 6.92 to 1
and this is actually exactly the same as
it was last year
and if we look at the ratio between our
lowest paid employee and the average
chief officer it's five point five five
to one um and the ratio has actually
reduced from last year when it was five
point seven six to one so that's a
positive change
and also to mention when we do actually
have this sort of delayed pay award for
21 22 because the proposal around staff
on the lowest scale point scale point
one is a higher um
increase than for the rest of the
workforce that will actually improve
further so again they'll be and the
ratio will improve
um so that's always going to stay on pay
ratios and then i'm just going to talk
about the gender pay gap
so as you'll know every year we work out
agenda pay gap figures and then we
report them and then we start to
consider the reasons for our gap so we
can see what we can do to try and move
the dial forward in this area
so the figures we will report at the end
of this march are based on payroll data
from march 21
as there's always a year-long time lag
between pulling off the information and
then having to report
um
so this year traffic council's overall
mean pay gap is 8.14
and the median is 10.77 so we've
produced in two different ways two
different types of average
um they're both um in favor of male
employees
um and there are you know
historically a number of influencing
factors which combine to give our gap
which i'll just briefly mention
one of the big things is that we have a
massively female
workforce so we've got 76 percent of
staff are female and 24 male
we also employ a really high number of
part-time roles um so 20 sorry 49
opposed to part-time and these roles
tend to attract females and there's
evidence to show that part-time roles
pay less than full-time roles
um but when you actually when when we do
the gender payout we do lots of
different pieces of data to really
understand what's going on
and one way we look at it is we look at
the agenda pay gap for part-time staff
and also for full-time staff separately
and when you look at part-time roles and
you see what the gender pay gap is it's
actually positive for women so women are
actually on higher hourly rates and
part-time roles in males in part-time
roles
so it's one point four or seven percent
sorry
it's um um yeah um
it's 1.47 mean sorry for females and 8.9
medium in favor of women that's really
positive
another really big contributory factor
for our gap is that we have lots of in
high services which are i think you know
culturally and traditionally tend to
attract more females and males so i'm
talking about catering roles cleaning
roles in schools
some of our passenger assistant roles
attached to schools and also a lot of
the care assistant and support worker
roles tend to be traditionally um more
occupied by females
um so you know if we don't if we take a
look at the workforce without these
roles our gap is quite a bit lower
um that's called occupational
segregation and it affects lots of
organizations you know you look at
different authorities gender pay gaps
they the differences will often be
explained by the makeup of their
workforce which services they have in
house and which services are outsourced
because when you pull pull off the
gender pay gap figures it's based on
your directly employed workforce not um
any other you know subcontracted staff
basically
um
so our
gender pay gap has reduced um so last
year we had a mean pay gap of 9.75
and a median pay gap of 15.46
the median has reduced quite a lot
um
and you know both figures have reduced
since we started reporting back in
2017.
um
what we'll be doing now is we will be
getting ready to report the figures
officially on the national reporting
data
website
and we're also going to be doing some
further analysis of the data to
understand more what's going on and
what's changed from last year really
and then to think about what we can do
to try and reduce the gap further um so
you know more work to be done and we
also link that in some of our qualities
work stream um strands i think as well
um
so you know
due to the makeup of our workforce i
think the reality is that it might be
very difficult for an organization like
ourselves you know with all the best
intentions to get to zero gap um but as
long as we understand and we work um to
affect change in the places where it
makes the most sense to do so
it has the most impact and i'll stop
there and invite any questions
dusty thank you very much
lots of interesting data in there um
anybody
any questions or comments
don't see any hands raised
no final call right we happy to move on
with that one then
um
we'll move on to then uh item number six
the local government pension scheme
discretions policy statement
okay thanks councilwoman i'll just um
again introduce it so this is um so the
local government pension scheme is as we
know a statutory pension scheme um
whilst its rules are set out in acts of
parliament it does allow employers to
make certain discretionary decisions
and this policy is an updated position
since the last statement was written in
2015
with minimal changes proposed so we need
to keep under review our policy
statement and so this is a refresh of
that policy statement so we're going to
bring kaiten um again to just take us
through the the highlights of the um
of the policy um statement and just to
say that you know
kate's work really closely with the um
pensions lead and the director of
finance um who both of which
unfortunately want well the pensions
lead isn't able to attend a session
today um
but both of which are happy with the um
refreshed policy statement
so i'll i'll start now
bring kate in
yeah i was going to keep this family
brief but i supposed to say we reviewed
the policy decisions for the discretions
just to make sure they're all
appropriate
workable in practice and affordable very
conscious obviously of you know um
budgets
um you know and in doing this we've also
benchmarked with other local authorities
just to make sure our approach is in
keeping and make sense
um as anthony said our director of
finance has been involved in agreeing
our policy positions
and to ensure compliance with the local
government pension scheme and hmrc
regulations we've also um contacted um
greater manchester pension fund um to
review our proposed um changes just to
make sure they're comfortable with
everything and that's all technically
correct as well
um so if you've had a chance to go
through or you know you'll understand
there is some repetition
of some of the discretions as there are
sections for the different pension
regulations um with the most recent um
to the older ones
also to mention that some of the
discretion scenarios particularly around
the compensatory added years pension
payments are likely to be very very rare
because some of them relate to payments
that ceased you know over 15 years ago
but they're under very unlikely
situations with family members however
we do need to have a position agreed in
case that scenario should ever rise
um
obviously pensions is a pretty technical
field and i think the report is probably
not the lightest read ever
so i wasn't going to go through it in
detail but
if you want to support any questions i
can answer them and anything i'm unable
to we can
take to our pension specialist and come
back to you on
and i'll stop there
okay thank you kate for that um anybody
have any comments on that or questions
at all
again no no hands up nobody wants to get
into the nitty-gritty of
don't blame them
this evening
um nobody wants to take that one on okay
on a monday
early in the week maybe
um so if we move on then to the um
the item seven which is the agency spend
october to december 2021
okay and again i i've got the easy job
of introducing the report so
um the report narrative um continues to
demonstrate reliance on temporary staff
in a number of areas
as you know we heard from children's
services and strategic lead
at the last meeting of some of the
initiatives that are in place to support
recruitment into those key social work
and social care roles so um tracy um
from the resourcing team is um going to
present the um agency spend reports
um which is the quarter three reports
of december so i'm going to invite tracy
who's uh resourcing strategically to
come in and take you through the reports
sorry i'm just looking for me
paige
sorry about this
yeah good afternoon everyone um
i hope you've all um had an opportunity
to read the report um therefore i'll
pull out some of the kind of key
information
um overall the the spend has increased
um although in adults it has reduced but
only very very slightly
and the biggest increase in spend again
is within our children services
and as you're all aware um
the the challenges in recruiting
qualified social workers is not it's not
only a regional uh challenge but also a
national challenge as well um and from a
hr perspective hr and
my resourcing team have continued to
support obviously the services with
their recruitment and as angela just
mentioned uh jude from children's at the
last employment committee meeting gave
quite a detailed overview of all the
great work that they're doing in
children's services
and to try and mitigate and reduce the
reliance on agency spend and bring in a
more
permanent workforce
and
i'm just having a sorry about this
uh
yeah we've also as well and i think jude
mentioned it at the last meeting we also
we've also engaged uh tripod who's an
external recruitment agency to help um
to work in partnership on a social work
recruitment campaign and that that is
still ongoing and we're continuing to
support that as well
um we've also been supporting adults as
well to develop uh support the
development of their recruitment and
retention strategy and we've put out
quite a lot of social media campaigns as
well across both of the adults and the
children's directorate again to try and
attract and recruit a more permanent
qualified social
care workforce
um and we are seeing some some
improvements in in those areas and you
know and starting to bring in more more
permanent staff i think is further work
that is still ongoing and one of the
areas that we are looking at is updating
our greater jobs websites as well and
looking at putting blogs new blogs on
there and videos as well to try and
encourage um
people and obviously promote our unique
selling point and coming working for
traffic council
so yeah i don't know if there's any
anybody's got any questions
um
anybody any questions on that one
yeah um
is that counselor german gopro
question for accuracy really it's
probably me getting it wrong again but
the bottom of page 58 i mean this
this is an example really
it said that the agency spend on
children's services there's 1.2
million plus
and that involved
98 active assignments
so so 90 if you call that 100
more or less and do the math
that's only like 12
8
863 per head which doesn't seem an awful
lot
do they
i mean
i don't know whether these are part-time
appointments but i mean even if they are
it still seems
incredibly low is is
is that correct am i reading probably
reading it wrong
no no that that that is correct yeah
it's the number of assignments between
the october and december and then
appendix 2 is the number of live
assignments post post december um that
was that we still have um that was still
that was still engaged
and i think it will depend on some of
those will be part-time some of them
will will be full-time um
agency workers
can i said yes if that's what we're
paying and that's probably where they're
leaving
but i mean i i've obviously seen the
report that was put together that angela
mentioned up front and a
a mismature opportunity to comment on it
then but
i mean it was a very comprehensive good
report well put together and uh it was a
lot a lot of information are taken in a
short space of time but
the impression you get from that is
despite our best efforts the situation
seems to be getting more difficult
really in in the market
so i mean i don't know really
you know what what can do about it but
keep but but keep trying really but um
yeah i mean it is a good report do i
mean uh
are we covering it with
all those vacancies which is quite a lot
of are they all being covered by agency
staff
i think the majority i think from um
what jude said at the the last meeting i
think the majority of vacancies are
being covered by agency staff although
there are a handful that are not that
that's just remain vacant
um and we are continuing to support um
both the children's and adults with
their recruitment campaign and their
recruitment and retention strategy and
looking at how you know what what else
we can do to attract people to come and
work for trafford council one of the
things that was put in place last year
was a market supplement for our
experience um
qualified social workers at band 89 but
it might be still early days at the
moment to determine what the impact that
that has had
and i think in terms of the improvement
journey and the implementation of phase
one i still think that's probably in in
its early stages at the moment
and but we are kind of working with the
external uh company tripod uh with a
huge social media campaign which we keep
under review constantly
and to try and attract more passive um
so more passive candidates that are not
maybe looking to change their job
and or attract people back into back
into social care and all that runs
alongside of some of the internal
programs that we've got to grow our own
at the step up program
and the at the apprenticeship program
that we we offer to internal staff and
after our frontline program as well
um
but i think again it's just i think it's
just an ongoing challenge of both
regionally and nationally i think we're
all kind of
fishing in the same pool uh to try to
crack attract staff to come to come and
work for a traffic council and that's
the same across across the piece
yeah i'm just saying thanks jason thank
you
thank you for that um aiden did you want
to say something
just i think really something in a
similar vein to what dave was sort of
referring to their i suppose i've noted
in
the report in paragraph 2.1.7 i think it
says that there's going to be some work
undertaken to
fully understand the resistance to
consider a permanent contract with
trafford
um amongst children's services social
workers and i was wondering um if you
had any information about whether or not
we have managed to start to understand
that picture yet because one of the
things that's really striking is just
the numbers in those appendices i think
if i'm reading appendix 2 by
there's 44
um level 3 and level 3a
currently live assignments in terms of
agency workers just in children's
services um
so i was just wondering if you had if
that work is still ongoing and what that
looks like and whether or not we are
starting to understand if there is a
specific problem around
that directorate and retaining people
and getting agency workers onto
permanent contract i suppose
yeah i'm aware that that is still an
ongoing kind of um kind of program um
and i know jude i think updated last
time in that when they implemented phase
one of the the improvement in the new
redesign
um agency workers were invited to to
apply for those roles and and we're
hoping that as that that as we move
through that improvement journey
more agency staff will look to convert
to a more permanent role with with
traffic council but it has i think it
has been quite quite a slow process but
i think it will continue to try and
encourage agency workers to come come
and work with us on a more permanent
basis
okay um
anything else on that any other
questions or comments from anyone
anywhere i don't see any more hands up
uh so if everyone's happy uh i'll move
on then to item eight which is the
quarterly report on the exemptions to
the sickness policy
and good afternoon ah i'm going to bring
bevin she's already here come on in ben
thank you good afternoon um yes i've got
the the quarterly report for the
occupational sick pay exceptions which
we know is the discretionary scheme
which we run across the council
so for the last quarter i can confirm
that there have been eight um requests
that were received
and all eight were approved
those eight came from three directorates
so in adults two were received in
children's there were five and in
finance 19 there was one
and therefore a variety of reasons and
probably worthy of notice that three of
them relate to long covered
and the others are for all individual
and a wide variety of circumstances
thank you any questions
happy anyone anything to comment or
questions on that
no i think if that's it then um i think
if um
from right we've come to the end of the
agenda and so thank you very much for
all the reports they've all been
fantastic and really well
presented as usual um i think
a lot of the time there's no questions
because the reports are so good in the
first place that we've got everything we
need to know straight away
and so thank you very much for that and
um i'll close the meeting there
good night
thank you good night good night
everybody